all right and now we turn our attention
to the 2024 GOP Primary where aake ramas
Swami is actually accusing Nikki Haley
of trying to get rich off the war in
Israel well here now to respond as
former Ambassador and Governor Nikki
Haley you know I I've interviewed uh uh
vake a number of times Everyone's
entitled to their opinion you know but I
don't think she's a child I think she is
somebody that like many politicians in a
position to get wealthier from
War what the hell does that mean now
he's on later tonight what would you
like to tell him and what's your
response to
him I mean Sean I quit responding to him
I don't trust him I don't think that he
has any credibility he throws these
things he blames and says everybody's
bought and paid for with no evidence
whatsoever it's why I think he's sinking
in the polls and you know quite honestly
his comments on Israel disqualified him
for me a long time ago and and so you
know it doesn't bother me what he says
what I do want to talk about is the fact
that 5 years ago I gave a speech at the
UN and that speech talked about the fact
that we I had worked with the Israelis
and they had maps and those Maps were
from Hamas and Hamas basically had these
maps that said if they were able to get
past the barrier these were the quickest
easiest ways to get into the Israeli
communities to kill as many Jews as they
could and what I said then was we have
to make sure that we never let them get
cross that barrier now I have actually
been in Israel and seen the tunnels I've
been on the border of Lebanon and seen
the 130,000 Rockets looking back at
Israel I've been on the border of Gaza
I've been in at um Ida refugee camp I've
actually seen how the Palestinians live
I looked at the buildings and saw the
graffiti that said kill the Jews hate
the Jews I've worked with organizations
that the un funds that I stopped us
funding that would actually have
textbooks and they would have math
problems like if you have five Jews and
you kill four Jews how many Jews are
left so when you hear of anything trying
to give sympathy to what is happening in
Gaza don't listen to it because I've
been there I've been in those tunnels
where do they put those tunnels what do
they put in those tunnels they put
equipment they put ammunition they hide
hostages and that's where they hide to
try and do harm to Israel and where are
those tunnels they put them under
schools under hospitals because they
know Israelis value life and when you
look at what happened the other day how
horrific it was when they were dragging
bodies around the streets what were they
saying death to Israel death to America
that's what we're dealing with that's
why we have to eliminate Hamas Governor
Ambassador like you I've been in those
tunnels like you i' I've actually been
there during you know uh flare up that
have happened uh I've been there when
border towns I've been to the border of
Gaza where a nearby town uh the night
before had been hit with a rocket I've
seen the Iron Dome in action uh I was
driving a car with a group of people
when we were there during the flare up
about 150 200 yards away we saw a rocket
land and blow up uh we saw a kabut had
been hit the night before and nothing
but trapnel to destroy human beings I
mean glass and n
I mean maximum the hope is Maximum
Destruction capability um and this is a
real clear present danger now my
interpretation of prime minister
netanyahu's remarks is Gaza will no
longer exist in its current form and
that Hamas will no longer be able to
operate from there with such close
proximity as you have seen with your own
eyes as I have seen and fire their
Rockets from Gaza into Israeli towns any
longer I believe that capab ability will
be wiped out I believe that's the only
answer do you
agree we have to completely eliminate
Hamas but what I want the American
people to remember is we've seen the
images and as horrific as they are and
as heartbreaking as all of this is we
are saying right now eliminate Hamas I
can tell you because it happened all the
time at the UN when they start that
ground game when Israel starts to move
in to eliminate Hamas further you're
going to have all the SE other countries
and you're going to have Americans say
you need to show constraint you need to
be able to pull back no they need to
eliminate Hamas we are supporting Israel
now because they've been hit but the
more important part is we have to
support them when they hit back as well
don't tell them to stop they saw Too
Much Death they saw too much destruction
and Hamas will do it again we have to
eliminate them regardless of how they
try and intimidate us and we have to
remember the reason we have Israel's
back is because it's not that we need
that Israel needs America America needs
Israel they're the Frontline of Defense
to this Jihad terrorism and that the
next thing they want is America and we
should never be so arrogant to think
that we don't need friends uh Governor
Ambassador thank you for being with us
we appreciate your time hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else